[Applause]
that's 15 14 13 12 11 10 9 we have
ignition sequence start the engines are
on 4
7:51 a
there's a fire
[Music]
[Applause]
and over an enemy that two-zero-niner
[Applause]
[Music]
how does it feel up there oh yeah look
at that picture on there
Suzie earth coming up Wow every you got
a color film Jim Amy I roll a color man
they're pretty thick oh I got a radar
they're beautiful shot
[Applause]
good afternoon
good luck dad hi my name is ron garan
i'm here with my friends nicole stott
and a new shawn sorry and we want to
share some stories with you today but
before we do we want to set the stage by
talking about one specific image now
images have the power to change our
perspective they can change the way we
see our world that gets change the way
we see ourselves and there's probably no
image that has changed the way we see
ourselves more than an image that was
taken on Christmas Eve 1968 now the
story begins 50 years ago atop the
tallest the heaviest the most powerful
rocket ever brought to operational
status the Saturn 5 sat the crew of
Apollo 8 the mission objective was to be
the first crewed spacecraft in history
to travel to the moon enter into orbit
around the moon and of course to return
back safely now this would propel the
United States in the race to be the
first on the moon to propel them ahead
of the of the Soviet Union but after
reaching the moon and entering into
orbit around the room the crew witnessed
something never seen before by human
eyes as the crew experienced the earth
rising from behind the lunar horizon I
wonder if they realize the significance
of that moment they had just become the
first humans in history to see the whole
earth as a planet and the first to
capture that for the rest of us this
famous photograph commonly known as
Earth rise is probably the most
influential photograph ever taken this
image showed us for the first time our
living planet our biosphere our earth it
revolutionized how we see the world how
we see ourselves with it's simple
message that we are one people traveling
on one planet towards one shared future
in this breathtaking beauty is a deep
heralding to the unity that to the unity
that we as a species are called to since
then less than 600 people have traveled
to space
the three of us standing before you have
had that privilege we were able to
escape the confines of our planet and
look back and profoundly experience
seeing our beautiful planet from the
vantage point of space I was born a long
long time ago in a country far far away
sad Iran I love the night skies I would
sleep outside summer nights and look at
those stars and I wanted to fly up there
and touch them I wanted to understand
what their might made out of I wanted to
understand what our world made out of us
and how its built this love of space
allowed me to you know exercise my
imagination when I was 12 years old
before I knew it there was a revolution
in Iran there were shouting screaming
burning buildings gunshots I was scared
I had never heard the gunshot before
before I could even adjust to that there
was a war there was an eight-year war
that broke out with between Iran and
Iraq and within the first year there
were bombings there were long lines for
food and fuel there were gunshots and
sirens we had to go to shelter
it was scary time for me but there was
one place I could always go at night and
look at the beautiful night skies and
let my imagination take me to a
different place to a different planet
perhaps some place that was peaceful
some place there were no gunshots some
place that I could take the rest of my
family and everyone who wanted to go
with me and be safe and be playful and
that's what I wanted to do on September
18 2006 I had the amazing opportunity to
fly to International Space Station for
anybody 11-day mission it was my dream
come true
I was now actually floating in space
where I wanted to go amongst those stars
that I dreamed out I was looking at our
planet
and I was able to see this beautiful
canvas of tans and Crimson's of the
desert with the deep greens of the
forests and highlighted by the whites of
the highest mountain peaks I could see
the glow of the serpentine rivers as
they float flowed into the sea and it
was an amazing colourful canvas that I
was looking at but what amazed me the
most was this deep blue colors the
different shades of blue of our ocean
which covers most of our planet our blue
planet and I was mesmerized by it I look
down on earth and what I could see and
feel was this energy life energy coming
from it I could see no borders no walls
nothing was dividing us we were all one
and the feeling that I got the sense of
oneness that I had with the planet and
with everyone else on it was something
that I wanted to share with everyone I
wanted to be able to tell everyone how
we're connected and we're all citizens
of one planet Earth that we're all
astronauts on this spaceship earth going
through the universe together and I
imagine how that would transform
everyone's lives so my dream of becoming
an astronaut was realized when I along
with the crew of sts-124 launched into
space aboard space shuttle Discovery I
remember that first day that first day
in space the most remarkable the most
memorable most amazing thing was when I
had the opportunity to look out of the
window for the first time when my tasks
are over I got to unstrap and float over
to a window it was just absolutely
breathtaking and I remember the first
thing that hit me was just how
incredibly thin our atmosphere appeared
and in that moment that sobering moment
I was hit with the realization that that
paper-thin layer is what's keeping every
living thing on this planet alive but in
spite of this fragility I couldn't help
fall in love with the beauty of our
planet it's a it's a constant dance of
color and light and motion and what was
really amazing and beautiful was to see
the colors change on the earth to see
thunderstorms casting long shadows
across the horizon and watch the clouds
turn from pink to red to grey and
finally to black and then as we crossed
into the dark side of the orbit to see
all the lights of the cities and towns
all the evidence of human activity all
of a sudden come to life and it really
gave me the sense that we live on a
living breathing organism now we saw
amazing things many amazing things in
space the paparazzi like flashes of
lightning storms dancing curtains of
Aurora's that seemed so close it was
almost as if we could reach out and
touch them now this was an incredibly
overwhelming visual experience but it
was it was also much much more than just
a visual experience what I experienced
in space was a profound sense of
gratitude gratitude for the opportunity
to see the planet from that perspective
and gratitude for the planet that we've
been given and in some way I don't think
I'll ever be able to fully put into
words being physically detached from the
earth made me feel deeply interconnected
with everyone on it now although I
didn't have the the view of the Earth
that the Apollo 8 guys had nevertheless
from space I was able to look back and
see what we have always been one single
human family with a common origin and
now in a very real way I had a deep
awareness of the reality of our common
future and as you can tell we all maybe
it's just me we all share similar
feelings about our experience in space
even with some of the different twists
on the stories about it the underlying
reaction is the same flying in space
brings us back to earth we see a living
breathing planet it is our home it
brings us back to home and while there
are a lot of complex things that go on
while we're in
basse I came home with three very simple
lessons to share and that's that we live
on a planet we are all earthlings
and the only border that matters is that
thin blue line of atmosphere that
blankets us all
now these stunning views they remind us
of what it was like to be in space it is
like Ron said overwhelmingly
impressively beautiful and while it
looks like we're slowly passing over the
planet I know that we're traveling at
17,500 miles an hour or five miles a
second which means that we get one of
these stunning sunrises or sunsets every
45 minutes as we go around the earth
every 90 minutes pretty amazing and
these views also remind me like Ron said
how separated I was but how in contrast
to that physical distance I don't think
I ever felt any more connected to
everyone and everything below me than I
did right then every time I looked out
the window there was some new surprise
the vastness of the oceans there was a
depth and color and texture to them that
I had never experienced her felt before
and when I looked out the window I
wanted to see familiar things I wanted
to see Florida from space
I considered Florida my home but very
quickly Florida became just this special
place on earth that's my home I don't
know when exactly that happened but I
believe me it does I started thinking
about Earth not just his home but as a
planet as a planet in space and as a
living organism I couldn't deny the
interconnectivity of everything that I
saw below me and I started thinking
about us all as earthlings so during my
six months in space I got into a routine
where I would almost say goodnight to
the earth when my tasker over it was
time to get ready for bed I would go to
the cupola which is this window to
observatory on the bottom of the space
station and that would just gaze at the
earth for a little while and as I would
gaze back at this at this beautiful
scene I would
wonder what the next 50 years would look
like how far would we progress and
overcoming the challenges facing our
planet and as I would take in this
beautiful scene I would routinely be hit
in the gut with a sobering contradiction
between the beauty of our planet and the
suffering that exists on our planet what
I couldn't reconcile was the
indescribable beauty of our seemingly
peaceful blue planet suspended in this
inky blackness and yet on that same
planet there are untold tragedies that
happen every day so as many of our
colleagues report from the ISS you can
actually see the negative effect humans
have made on our planet clear cutting of
forests mountaintop removal operations
industrial pollutants entering rivers
giant crop burnings that that cover a
whole areas of the of the globe that
sends smoke to the limits of the
atmosphere up to you know to cover
almost entire continents I watched into
space with the belief that we already
right now have all the technology all
the resources necessary to solve many if
not all the problems facing our planet
and so I spent a good deal of my time
Earth gazing pondering the question if
this is true why do they still remain
and more importantly what can we do to
address these challenges the seeds - the
answer to that question lies in our
shared experience of living and working
on the International Space Station and
the valuable lessons that experience
gives us for life here on earth so for
my time in space this was my home this
beautiful masterpiece in space the
International Space Station or the ISS
there is no better example of living off
the grid than the ISS there are systems
that regulate - all the conditions that
we need to survive the right amount of
oxygen for us to breathe clean water for
us to drink but these systems are not
automatic
they require care and maintenance and
attention and we go about our daily
activities our science experiments in
space and these life-support systems are
what keep us alive and an otherwise
lifeless expanse of space
through the ISS we have created
mechanical systems in space that do the
best we can to mimic what our planet
does for us naturally so as you heard on
space station we rely on machines these
machines are you know our life-support
system and we take good care of them and
you can bet if something goes wrong with
any of those machines everyone will come
together collaborate and make sure that
we fix it immediately because we can't
live without them so we're hoping that
we can apply the same sense of urgency
here on our planet we're all crew of the
spaceship earth and we need to take care
of our life-support system to have a
beautiful peaceful spaceship that we can
all live on here at home we need to come
together collaborate and be able to fix
and restore our life-support system in
the words of legendary Buckminster
Fuller we should learn how to become
crew of the spaceship earth not just
passengers and on the ISS we are acutely
aware of the conditions that are
necessary to sustain life and with our
help the machines do this for us when we
return from our time in space though
even though we intellectually knew it
before we become acutely aware that we
require these same conditions down here
on earth to survive but down here on
earth it's not the machines that do this
for us
they aren't creating those conditions
it's life itself it's the living
breathing planet it's the humans and
plants and animals it's the chemical
mixtures of air and the oceans it's the
earth itself all interconnected that
creates these conditions it's
biodiversity and as you've heard tonight
the two most important things about the
international space station or that we
have these amazing strong international
relationships that it's built on
but perhaps more importantly is that
we're living there like we should be
living here on spaceship earth we must
all work together to protect our
biosphere the life-support systems of
our planet for ourselves and for the
benefits of the countless possible next
generations and for all life because of
this we decided to get all of our
astronaut friends together and we've
launched a couple years ago an
organization called constellation and
our first mission is inspired by the
work of yo Wilson's half Earth and the
Convention on Biological Diversity so we
are working to advocate for and to point
attention to this important work and so
that's together we could inspire the
actions necessary for nations to sign
and embrace the pivotal Convention on
Biological Diversity in 2020 we want to
bring together astronauts that we are
bringing together astronauts from all
around the world to share their profound
experiences of seeing the beauty of the
our planet from space from their
different national cultural religious
backgrounds and partner with National
Geographic Society and work with all the
various organizations signed up for
campaign for nature and we want to work
with all of you in addition to that
advocating for this most important set
of goals in our civilizations history so
our shared vision constellations na
Geo's hopefully all of you here in this
room and anyone that you touch outside
of these rooms is to come together and
make sure that we can preserve 30% of
Earth's biodiversity by 2030 and
increase that to 50% by 2050 we also
need to make sure that we meet all the
17 sustainable development goals and we
do everything possible to make sure that
we don't have global warming exceed the
limits of one and a half degree Celsius
this is just called Good Housekeeping
it's called planet planetary stewardship
and we have to all work together and
aspire to live up to this
and no matter where we're from what we
do what nation were from we have to do
it together and we have to come together
to make our planet safe again our time
in space has proven that when we start
from a foundation of awe and wonder we
open the mind to new ideas and solutions
that encourage cooperation together and
it's only through profound cooperation
and a shared mission that will build a
future that we all want to experience
here on earth Bo and Wonder are the
secret ingredient that changes
everything they can allow us to create a
better future
there should be no passengers on
Spaceship Earth only crewmates and as
crewmates we are all responsible for the
minding of the ship and the care of each
other I hope you can tell that we as
constellation as our crew are excited to
be joining National Geographic as a
voice for the campaign for nature and
together we know that we can create a
positive future where all life thrives
thank you
well I think we can agree that that
powerful opening is a great tip for the
festival but also a great tip for our
first panel conversation on the new era
of discovery you know technology is a
driver and so much of our daily lives
helping us explore the world around us
and make decisions on what route to take
to work
what jacket to bring as we walk out the
door so how can we use technology to
advance the exploration of our planet
National Geographic is committed to
developing innovative technology with
our national geographic labs team I want
to share one exciting project that the
labs group currently has in development
called the canopy drone here's a video
of the drone being tested in a forest
canopy piloted by a labs team member via
remote control National Geographic is
working with the Illinois and Illinois
Institute of Technology to incorporate
autonomy into the drone so it's capable
of flying and navigating through very
complex environments without the need
for GPS or the need of a human pilot
this technology will radically reduce
the cost of monitoring and it will
accelerate our ability to conduct
biodiversity and wildlife monitoring in
densely forested areas where you cannot
see the animals from above the speaker's
you are about to meet are also using
technology to help them explore the
world and gather data in new and
exciting ways with that I'd like to
introduce our first speaker
Heather Lynch is a quantitative
ecologist studying penguin populations
in Antarctica very NatGeo
please welcome Heather Lynch
well thank you very much
Antarctica is changing and nowhere is it
changing more rapidly than on the
Western Antarctic Peninsula where it's
getting warmer wetter and the sea ice is
breaking up earlier each year these
changes are having major impacts on the
wildlife in the region and as a penguin
biologist specializing in population
dynamics it was one of the highlights of
my research career when National
Geographic approached me as they
prepared their November 2018 feature
special on the region they asked me well
how many penguins are there in the
region and do we know how their
populations have changed and you can see
my answer in the graphic behind me the
Antarctic Adelie penguin their
populations have crashed even as the
more sub-antarctic Gentoo population has
skyrocketed we know that because on the
Western Antarctic Peninsula we can
survey these populations the
old-fashioned way accessing colonies by
boats and Counting nests one by one but
there are some colonies that are too big
too remote to inaccessible to be
monitored this way in fact it turns out
that the majority of our uncertainty
about how many penguins there are stem
from colonies like zabadov ski island
behind me we can't count individual
penguin heads to monitor these
populations so to solve this problem my
lab and several others around the world
are pioneering the use of satellite
imagery as an alternative method of
monitoring these populations now when
we're monitoring them from satellites
we're not counting individual penguin
nests anymore instead what we're doing
is we're using the the guano stain that
pinkish-red stayed you see in the
photograph and it turns out that that
guano stain that's left behind at the
colony we can use it to area to estimate
the number of penguins that are breeding
within it so satellite imagery has
radically transformed our ability to
monitor penguins not just the ones that
we can access directly but all around
Antarctica and not just in one year but
in every year in fact satellite imagery
can do one step better because it turns
out that the spatial pattern of the
Penguins on the landscape
with its one big area or they're
fragmented across the landscape that's
telling us something important about the
health of the colony whether it's
increasing or whether it's declining and
may be at risk of critical collapse so
satellite imagery is not just giving us
more information it's actually in many
cases giving us better information so
the challenge now becomes not can we
access these colonies to survey the
populations directly but how do we
possibly deal with the volumes of
information that we're now getting we
get tens of thousands of satellite
imageries from Antarctica every year and
there just aren't enough penguin
biologists in the world to annotate and
to interpret all of that satellite
imagery so the key now is in automation
and with help from the National Science
Foundation and NASA and most recently
the AI for Earth program my lab is
pioneering the use of computer vision
and machine learning to automate the
detection of penguin colonies and
satellite imagery one of our big early
successes in this arena was our
discovery in the danger islands of
several very very large Adelie penguin
colonies the danger islands is an island
chain off the northern tip of the
Antarctic Peninsula that is so small it
does not even appear on maps of
Antarctica and yet it turns out there
are more Adelie penguins in the
Antarctic in the danger islands than the
entire rest of the Antarctic Peninsula
combined and yet the vast majority of
these penguins were not known to exist
before we discovered them in Landsat
imagery using automated algorithms that
would find guano forests in places we
never expected it in response to our
discovery the proposed marine protected
area for the Western Antarctic Peninsula
was expanded by upwards of 2 million
hectares to include this important
biological hotspot and it's such a
beautiful illustration of how better
technology really can lead to better
conservation we can also use satellites
to plan expeditions to the region like
we did when we went to the danger
islands and that allowed us to deploy
another amazing tool for penguin
conservation and that's drones drones
allow us to map up in map out in
extraordinary detail all of the Penguins
at a colony and we can count
each individual nest but drones also
allow us to reconstruct a
three-dimensional model of these
colonies as you can see in the lower
left of the screen and these
three-dimensional models allow us to
understand how penguin colonies are
responding to the landscape terrain but
also how over hundreds or thousands of
years of occupation penguins are
actually shaping the islands on which
they live the threats that face penguins
are as urgent as they've ever been but
with machine learning and computer
vision drones and satellite imagery we
have the capacity to monitor their
populations and respond to threats like
never before I'm super excited to see
where technology will take penguin
conservation over the next decade and
now I hope you're excited as well so
thank you very much
Thank You Heather that was terrific so
next we have a pair of explorers who
work side-by-side in the same lab
looking at life in the deep sea or what
Bob Ballard likes to remind us can be
called the final frontier
please welcome marine ecologist Whitney
Goodell and ocean conservation ecologist
Jonathan Giddens so I'm an ocean
ecologist and I study the deep-sea what
I love about ecology is that it's not a
study of things but a study of
relationships within a system and a deep
perspective of ecology also looks at the
relationship between people and nature
and I developed this like this
perspective because when I grew up I
would draw everything that I learned
about at school every subject had a
journal and I would stay up sometimes
all night illustrating the pages and
through drawing I learned to see nature
as a whole and not something with just
little parts that are subtractive
because in a drawing things make sense
in relation to everything else and so I
believe in the tradition of the early
naturalists that art is a partner in the
scientific exploration of the deep sea
I'm Whitney Goodell I'm a marine
ecologist and a National Geographic
fellow with exploration technology labs
something that I hear a lot and I've
actually already heard it a couple times
this week from some of you probably is
oh you work with the ocean I always
wanted to be a marine biologist when I
was a kid I on the other hand when I was
five years old I told my family on a
trip to Hawaii we were heading to the
beach and sorting out the day's
activities and I told my family I didn't
want a snorkel the ocean was this
unknown place I didn't know what was
below the surface and I didn't want to
go snorkeling around
the unknown which is kind of an ironic
start to my career and my character but
it really begs the question what else
don't we know and how is that limiting
us the deep seat you've heard it before
we know more about the surface of the
Moon or the surface of Mars than we do
about the bottom of the ocean the deep
sea is a huge unknown the deep sea is
the Earth's last frontier
it's often pictured as a desolate place
so remote that it might as well be
another planet but the ocean makes up
99% of the living space on this planet
and only 5% of the deep-sea has been
explored so we do not know our own home
up until relatively recently the
challenge had been well how do we
actually get there so it was not even a
hundred years ago that naturalist BB and
Engineer Barton devised the bathysphere
a two-ton ball of steel that they
crawled inside and went a half a mile
deep down into the bottom of the ocean
off of Bermuda but imagery and
photography had not advanced enough at
that time to take pictures there so what
Beebe did is he called on a telephone
line up to the surface to artist
bosserman
on the surface and as he peered out of
the portholes in the deep she was up
there drawing and painting these
creatures that he described as he
discovered this area so while technology
took the two men down to the bottom of
the ocean it was art that brought the
deep sea into the hearts and minds of
people
now with the deep ocean Dropcam
developed by National Geographic
exploration technology lab the deep sea
is in reach like never before
it's instead of a two-ton ball of steel
it's just bigger than a basketball and
it goes down to the surface sorry you
know it goes from the surface down to
the bottom of the ocean and takes video
footage high-definition video footage of
the seafloor so here we're seeing a
sixgill shark down at 900 meter
under crushing pressures this is far far
below diving depths under crushing
pressures and in perpetual darkness
until the Dropcam illuminates the scene
one more back so how it's programmed to
record for a number of hours then so
well we had a video but it's not playing
anyways imagine so it's a program to
record there it is ok still imagine so
it records and then it when it's done
recording it pops up so that it releases
its weight pops up to the surface and
then sends a chirp over VHF radio where
we can use an antenna and locate where
it is and thereby image the deep like
never before
and because this technology now comes in
travel-size it can go all over the world
so we actually have video footage like
what you saw a couple slides ago from
all of these points on the globe and
this is growing but these cameras really
open up opportunities for they open up
the doors to opportunistic deployments
so if a ship is going somewhere and
they're doing research off that ship
well great let's get some cameras on
there throw them overboard let's see
what's down there and so this is really
helping us build a spatial understanding
of where things live but it's really
cool that we could take it one step
further and we can start exploring why
do things live where they live so in
order to explore that we pull in data we
pull in different kinds of data like
habitat data and sea surface temperature
or ocean chemistry and we can start
layering on that information over what
we already have over our points and so
we start with our points we spend we can
look at spatial things like how far away
is it from different habitats like
trenches or plateaus is it near
spreading ridges what's the sea surface
temperature does that matter
what's the ocean chemistry phosphate
concentrations nitrate so we can start
looking at all of this information that
already exists we can layer it on and
start really understanding the
differences between each of these places
that we have video footage
and by that we can really start
exploring the relationships between
these things so what the video footage
that you saw in a process of annotation
which is identifying and counting the
species present I construct biodiversity
indices so that we can map biodiversity
in the deep sea and with the
environmental variables that Whitney
showed I can model the relationship
between biodiversity and its environment
so that we can better understand and
inform management of these systems based
on science but the process of discovery
does not stop there this is from a
recent expedition to the Seychelles
where we were collecting imagery of the
seafloor but I was also using
imagination to sense my relationship
with the ocean in deep time and these
are the types of transformative
experiences that I want to share from
these places so as scientists and
explorers we often get to go to these
places that are remote and wild and
beautiful and not that many people get
to go there and I want everybody to feel
connected to the ocean as a thing of
beauty that they're a part of and so I
think that going forward we can bridge
art and science and technology to
together not only go further but also
bring back the on wonder that we find so
please follow us into the deep and if
there's anybody also interested in
incorporating science into your art into
your science science into your art
please reach out I'd love to speak with
you so the deep sea really is our big
unknown and this you know how can we
protect something how can we properly
protect something that we don't know the
earth is changing really fast and we are
not letting excuses like it's hard to
get there it's hard to study we're not
letting that stop us from learning about
this place that makes up well over half
of the earth so exploration and analysis
really provide us the information
necessary to start understanding the
things and and really start building
what we need to move forward it's going
to take critical action and appropriate
appropriately designed management in
order to conserve this part of our earth
for ocean conservation we really need to
collect connect and protect thank you
guys so much
great stuff thank you Whitney Thank You
Jonathan
our final speaker uses artificial
intelligence to catalog bio acoustics in
species to learn more about biodiversity
please welcome Holger clink hi I'm
exploring nature by eavesdropping and
what I would like to do today is to
present a few highlights of projects we
are currently working on first I would
like to take you south to the Central
American rainforest which you can see
behind me and this is what the
rainforest sounds like during the night
it's very much driven by the
vocalizations in this case of insects
and we can visualize the soundscape to
make more sense of it let me briefly
talk you through what you're seeing here
so on the x-axis we have the time in
this case four days of continuous data
we collected in Panama on the y-axis we
have the frequency of the picture of the
sound and then color-coded you can see
the intensity of the sound signals we
are recording so in this specific case
we have during the day one cicada
species which makes a real lotta noise
and during the night we have 10 cricket
species which are calling a lot but the
species where are the family of animals
we are mainly interested in our
candidates there are about a hundred
different species of them in the area
we're working at and these are
grasshopper like insects which are
mimicking leaves you can see they come
in various shapes and sizes and they
play a really important role in that
ecosystem a lot of animals including
many of the 80 bat species we have there
but they even monkeys which specialize
on cated as a primary food source so we
also call them nature's popcorn that's
really what it comes down to
and we believe that by monitoring
catered at richness as well as abundance
and distribution of K tablets that is a
really good indication for us how well
the rain forest ecosystem is doing and
we're using acoustics to obtaining this
kind of information now I'd like to take
you even further south and no first I
want to show you what the KT that sounds
like candidates produce sounds which are
most often not audible to us because and
then ultrasonic frequency range but we
can manipulate the sound to make it
audible to you so you have to dominate
sound sources here the higher frequency
pitch sound this one that is an echo
locating batch who tries to find a
katydid to eat it and then the lower
frequency sound which you hear this one
this is a catered at americaís today
trying to attract a female so in
collaboration with National Geographic
and also Microsoft we're developing
machine learning tools which allow us to
extract these cause and species ID keyed
it it's from our long-term acoustic data
sets we're collecting into tropics so
now I'm going to take you even a little
bit further cells this is the end Arctic
ice field I spent a lot of time down
there during my PhD and I can tell you
if you're standing on the ice there's
not a whole lot going on maybe the
occasional penguin but listen to what
happens when you put in underwater
microphone which we call a hydrophone
underwater
and this is what it sounds like and in
my opinion this is one of the most
amazing sound escapes we have on earth
these are vocalizations produced by
penomet pinnipeds primarily in this case
what else eels and leopard seals which
are used to study during my PhD marine
mammals make a lot of noises underwater
and sound travels very efficiently in
the water so really passive acoustics is
a go-to tool for us to monitor abundance
distribution and also migration of
marine mammals including the endangered
ones in the ocean now I would like to
bring it back to the temperate regions
I'm at the Cornell Lab of Ornithology so
naturally I listen to a lot of birds as
well
birds are terrific indicators for
ecosystem health but they're also
challenging it's a taxonomic ly very
diverse group of animals there are over
10,000 species in the world and a lot of
them produce a variety of vocalizations
listen to this guy this is a bird which
you can find right now in your backyard
here in the DC area it's a brown
thrasher
and this species alone is known to
produce over 1,000 different sound types
so you can imagine that makes our
automated acoustic analysis a little bit
more challenging they also have a
tendency to call on top of each other
this is a very short snippet of sound I
recorded in SEP circuit in Ithaca where
my laboratory is and in this case we
have six passerine species vocalizing at
the same time doing a dawn chorus and
what you can see in here is that a lot
of their vocalizations overlap in time
and frequency and that's a real
challenge for us to tease this really
complex soundscape apart and figure out
what species are present at a certain
location but using again AI and deep
learning methods we have made really
great strides and cracking that knot
we're working on a project which is
called bird net and we're currently
training models which are able to
differentiate
1,000 bird species primarily North
American species acoustically and moving
forward we want to include more Central
and South American species in this
analysis to bring this tool into the
regions where we have time critical
conservation effort thank you this by
the way with a wet towel seals are one
of those species you heard vocalizing
earlier that was great Holger thanks for
that we're gonna have a quick panel
discussion in just a minute but before
we do I have a question for you sure so
how exactly do katydids vocalize so
kidded it's obviously don't have a
walker track like we do what they do is
recall it's tribulation so they're
rapping body parts against another and
what they do is they lift up their wings
and the base of monring they have a
sharp Ridge and on the base of the
second wing they have a row of knobs and
by wrapping those two against each other
they're producing this tribulation which
causes the wings to vibrate and to
produce sound and it's very interesting
also like they hear their ears are just
below the knee and the front legs and
they're very sensitive to sound
intensity so it's very directional
hearing and what's the females do they
can reorient their body and can figure
out from which direction the male is
calling and then headed to in that
direction where the male is actually
vocalizing so it's a little bit like
Marco Polo just alright well with that
why don't we invite our panel to the
stage here we can
[Applause]
so there were some themes that each of
you hit on and what I want to go to
right away and particularly jonatha
would you showed us in terms of art
playing a role in how we think about
science and exploration how do we think
about the impacts as technology advances
in the field of the human role in the
field you want to start us jonatha yeah
I think that it's really the
transformation comes on a personal level
it's a personal story that really can
connect people and go through this
transformation that we need and how we
relate with the natural world and I see
that technology is a great tool and it
is a great tool to connect us all but
what really we need art as a partner in
this process to help to kind of grab
people and help people to go through
these transformative experiences with
nature so that they connect and love
nature and see themselves see ourselves
as a part of this thing of beauty like
it's a it's as another kind of a message
instead of like do this or you're all
gonna die it's more just like hey you
know we're on this beautiful there's
just so much beauty to discover and kind
of have that transformation happen and
then have the technology connect us so
that it's not just separate little
things here and there but we have this
opportunity to really have a movement
with technology connecting us and
Heather with your satellite imagery that
you're using you're in extreme
environments where you're doing this
work and so there's always been some
limitation of how many humans can go
into the field so how do you see this in
terms of scale of the research and what
we understand you spoke to a little bit
of in your talk or absolutely well I
think that that technology really
expands the umbrella of exploration in a
way that I think is sometimes
underappreciated particularly when it
comes to supporting people who want to
be explorers but can't spend six eight
twelve months in Antarctica I mean I can
find a million penguins in the morning
and still get my kid off the bus in the
afternoon and that that I think really
speaks to the power of technology to to
really grow the community so you know
one of our explorers Sarah Park AK of
course she's been here before and she's
really using that satellite technology
for archaeology but what she's done is
she's really unleashed you know a whole
army of citizen scientists who are
helping to look at the work and better
informing where we go for archaeology
how do you see the role of citizens in
this technology that you're using
absolutely so we created what we call be
a penguin detective on a website that we
developed and it turns out that school
kids all over the country have really
responded to this and we'll have an
entire fifth-grade class look for new
penguin colonies and satellite imagery
and in fact we've had brand new emperor
penguin colonies that were discovered by
citizens out there just exploring
because they're interested and it really
gives them an opportunity to do exactly
what we're doing when we're looking at
the our satellite imagery so it's a
great way to to scale I'm going to get
more eyeballs but also just to get
people really excited so we need you
talked about the dropcam's and we're all
super excited about what we're seeing
from the dropcam's but you also talked
about sort of how we send them on ships
or if somebody's going here or whatever
how do you see ultimately scaling this
work well on the deployment side of it I
think that you know connecting so that
it's not just one team that's got to
kind of be doing all of it we can't be
everywhere we can't be doing all that it
really allows for sort of expanding out
so that we can kind of with some
training there can be people all over
the world that are you know if they're
connected to expeditions going on then
they can start kind of creating their
army of or sending off their army of
cameras and and really what that allows
for is it allows for you know footage
information from a huge network across
the globe it's not just restricted to
these tiny area what you talked about
using sort of layers of information and
data to begin to get a picture of our
deep sea you have over 200 explorers
here and as I said from over 50
countries
how do you see the opportunities for
collaborating with just the groups here
yeah that's a great question because the
data layers part is really an important
part of exploring these relationships
because sure you can get video footage
of animals but really what's going to
give us this information is how does
that relate to other things and that can
be so many different things the human
element is going to be a huge part in
understanding not only you know how
things are now but how they're going to
change in the future so connecting with
explorers that can give us information
across the globe about different types
of whatever types of information that
they are working with particularly with
the human element whether it's fishing
or pollution that's going into rivers
things like that all of that kind of
information can help tell the story of
what's going on so terrific opportunity
for explorers here to connect with you
and see how they can become part of that
network yes okay okay I don't really
understand how you deploy the technology
in the forest can you talk a little bit
about that yeah sure so we're building
very small and inexpensive passive
acoustic recorders which basically just
record sound 24/7 to an SD card so we
try to make them as small and
inexpensive as possible so we can
distribute them to as many people as
possible and especially the work we're
doing for example in Central Africa it
takes a lot of effort to get into these
jungle areas and we have to carry them
all in a backpack so you want to keep it
as light as possible and then we put
them out there and let them record for
weeks months at a time and then
typically we cover them and then use
machine learning to analyze the data but
moving forward we're really interested
in applying these machine learning
algorithms and more real-time
application especially for gunshots
poaching those kinds of application it's
really important that we get the
information to the people who are on the
ground very quickly and that will be the
next step for us to apply these mass
than a more real-time application you
know I spoke in my opening remarks about
how many great supporters we have in the
audience in addition to explorers
some have been truly generous with the
National Geographic Society both
individuals corporate partners Hubbard
Council etc how do you prioritize your
areas and what would you say to some of
our supporters if they're interested in
helping you scale this work yeah I mean
a lot is really technology development
and I really want to give a shout out to
some of the high-tech industry which
really helps us a lot so we you know we
get support from Microsoft with our AI
for Earth Grande we're also working on
the bird net project with Google and
really it's it's them helping us to push
the science to the next level so we
could not do that ourselves so really
it's a really energetic collaboration
which makes that happen and the more of
these tech companies we can help us out
that the better off we will be and that
was going to be my next question is how
engaged are you with the private sector
to bring them in and develop you know
side-by-side technologies or tools that
can help you in the field I guess I'll
keep things up so we we couldn't do a
lot of what we do without working with
some of the same tech companies that
Holger mentioned so that includes
360-degree camera technology in the
field all of the support that we've had
from Microsoft on the AI for Earth
project I'm just amazing opportunities
to go out to Microsoft headquarters and
learn from the very best out there so
that's been critical not only for me
personally but also for my students to
give them that opportunity it is as a
Tokarev mentioned a really nice synergy
between conservation and technology and
industry all in one yeah we we are
partnering with the National Geographic
Society exploration technology lab and
reaching out to different partners like
MIT Media Lab AI companies as well to
help try to figure out how to deal with
all this this data that we have
basically is over 35 terabytes of data
right now that
footage and so we're looking for help in
how to kind of pipeline the data to make
it a little bit more a little faster to
analyze so we definitely are looking for
partners in that yeah because you can
imagine when you're looking at video
footage of the deep ocean you have to
pull data out of that video so you just
have to sit there and watch it and that
takes a long time so we're working with
partners to kind of automate that and
streamline that make that a bit faster
you know one of the criticisms of AI as
much as we love advancements in
technology and especially those we can
apply in exploration and conservation is
that its pattern recognition and how do
you deal with this issue of patterns
today and whether they're the patterns
they should be or they're just the
patterns right now how do you sort of
look at time when you're really dealing
with artificial intelligence well it was
kind of a quite a controversial you know
question in an issue and I would I guess
my feeling is that to the extent that
we're able to support conservation I
don't care how it is that we got to that
answer and it might be a bit of a black
box but if we can make really good
short-term forecasts that are actually
meaningful to policy makers that's good
enough for me because a lot of what we
do in my lab is that kind of action
ready science and so however we get
there and we may not understand exactly
how the models work now we hope to get
there but I think it is improving
conservation so I couldn't help but
notice on your slides there were
numerous mentions of guano detection
also known as penguin poo exactly and we
know that that's the trail often
followed to tell us where colonies are
do you see with technology finding other
ways forward to uncover where they've
been and where they're going absolutely
well I I always say you know we will
never have fewer satellites in the sky
than we have right now like we will only
get more satellites more resolution
higher repeat times and so the future is
really bright and all of the work that
we do now investing in how to use those
new tools will only continue to grow and
blossom in the future so I absolutely
I'm sure that we'll have better better
sensors
more often in the future gran will just
have to see what what the technologists
developed great I have a question for
Holger but I do want to remind the
audience we're gonna have microphones so
we're gonna open it up for some
questions in just a moment so please
prepare your questions so Holger you
started with birds and you've really
kind of doubled down on insects can you
talk about that and sort of how you see
insects as kind of the key yeah i'm
taxonomically agnostic I mean a lot of
the research I'm doing is actually in
the marine domain still with marine
mammals but I mean we're challenging
we're facing different challenges in
different environments and depending
what your question is you need to pick
the right species which helps you to
answer that question katiedids are a
really great group to work with for many
reasons I mean they really play that
important role in the rain forest and
they're also a little bit easier than
the birds are because typically they
only produce one specific call which is
very stereotyped so from the detection
and the classification point of view
it's it's it's not as bad of a challenge
as birds can be great great we're gonna
open it up to the audience now for
questions and I do want to remind you
we're live streaming so it's very
important if you can to wait for the
microphone before you ask to ask your
question I think we have one down here
in the front microphone is coming to you
good afternoon thank you for your
presentations there were wonderful my
question is pertaining to the deep-sea
camera
what is its capability as far as maximum
depth what is the maximum depth that you
have accomplished thus far is the
feedback simultaneous or real life or is
it subsequently that you get the
information and finally do you have to
have a cable or something to bring it
down you know such a long
then retrieve it so the there are some
cameras and the original models were
full ocean depth and I believe that that
camera did go very near to full ocean
depth they've since made them smaller
the rating is about six thousand meters
and that's because that can reach a lot
of the ocean floor like we don't need to
go to the trenches every single time it
has no cable and that's what makes it so
portable and awesome is because you can
just program it to record for however
long and then with a wait take it down
to the bottom and then once it is gone
through its recording there's a burn
wire that sets it free and it's buoyant
so it goes up to the surface and then
can be retrieved at the surface and then
it's near instantaneous so we're not
streaming up but you just pick up the
camera go plug it into a computer and
look at your well okay couple hour
download or so but then you can look at
it from here in Campinas other questions
it's stationary yeah so it's just thrown
over and it sits at the bottom the back
so um I wanted to make a suggestion
which is that you tie the acoustic
monitoring to these deep cameras since
there's probably limits to what you can
detect with those cameras but I had an
earlier question which was I'm
particularly interested in coelacanths
and I've heard that I've heard the
suggestion that there's many many
species of coelacanths that and we've
just not sampling in the right area so I
was curious if there was any particular
project with the cameras looking for
coelacanth species sort of I just came
back from the Seychelles on an
expedition to the Seychelles so every
time the subs got in the water we were
definitely looking for coelacanth but
that's kind it would be more kind of
opportunistic it wasn't like we weren't
just setting out to look for coelacanth
but that's a good question we should go
back
there's an opportunity for someone right
there other questions do you have one in
the back there I'm sorry
okay well I'll fill the air while we're
waiting for one did we have one back
there I'm sorry oh yeah right here okay
you mentioned that you needed help on
the AI to analyze the video data from
the sea could you just briefly mention
the type of help you need yeah
so you are youing pattern-recognition
trying to analyze movements of yeah
there's several several pieces of that
and we're actually working with a team
right now that for a while they've been
building this tool that we will be able
to use soon I hope that there's the step
of simple event recognition right so is
something moving in the frame and then
you can go the next level of then trying
to start categorizing things maybe not
necessarily you know species
identification that's still well a
that's very difficult with these animals
even you know looking at the footage but
you know that really needs to be
humanized at this point looking at that
but yeah simple event recognition and
starting to categorize that really will
streamline the process quite a bit and
so that's that's in the works right now
it sounds like you guys should talk I
think we had a question right behind
here I don't know the question is still
there okay over here was it
and this will be our last question hi
Thank You Heather how much of the land
have you surveyed and how much you
haven't surveyed and how many remaining
penguin populations is your gut telling
you that there are left to be found so
we've surveyed the entire Antarctic
coastline and all the sub-antarctic
Islands we now do that at least annually
but we we try and get cloud free imagery
of all of Antarctica penguin colonies
every month but cloud free being the the
key issue there because many of these
areas are absolutely covered in clouds
we continue to find new penguin colonies
all the time so we found a very large
population of chinstrap penguins right
next to a colony that we had been
surveying for decades and then this last
season we're able to get there with
drones and I estimate something in the
order of 10 to 20,000 chinstraps on
those islands alone and increasingly
what we're finding are penguins showing
up where the glaciers have retreated and
particularly the Gentoo penguin whose
populations are growing they will seed
new colonies so new colonies are
actually being established because of
climate change and because of glacial
retreat and so I expect that we'll
continue to find these tiny little new
colonies popping up over time so every
year we find something new and as our
artificial intelligence sort of computer
vision algorithms get better and no
doubt we'll be finding them even faster
than before I see Jonathan Bailey
smiling over here so I guess that means
the panel has brought out all the things
we were hoping to cover here but before
we close I do have one question for the
panel
so obviously machines are taking over a
lot of life in different places and what
we've been talking about is machines
becoming explorers going into the field
do we think we might actually have a
National Geographic Explorer that's a
machine in the future I think
increasingly we're getting National
Geographic explorers who are programmers
who program those machetes because at
the end of the day somebody had to sit
there and make those models work and and
again I think that kind of speaks to you
know growing growing the pie for who can
contribute to exploration comments I
think that that kind of overlooks one of
the huge
values of explorers which is the ability
the creativity and the ability to
connect with other explorers and other
people I mean sure they're really good
at going out in the field and doing what
they do but the strength is really that
that human aspect it was a bit of a TIA
I think one thing we can all agree is
that you know when machines and humans
combine that's when we're at our best
and that's certainly true when we're out
in the field so thank you panel it's
been fascinating filmmaker and National
Geographic Explorer
sandesh kadar Wow
look at this this is incredible I was
actually hoping we'd stay a little bit
longer in space so I wouldn't have to
come in front of all of you this is
quite terrifying see Derek and Jubei
Beverly in the audience this is quite a
mesmerizing place to be right here